THOSE DEFENSEMEN.
LOOKING FORWARD TO WATCHING HIAT
FLYERS BRING THE PUCK IN.
FARA
CREATINGIT WIDE. AT
NET EARLY WITH THE REBOUND
OPPORTUNITY.
THIS LINE WOULD SOME EARLY
JUMPS AT CAMPBELL. FOR SURE.
HERE IS MORGAN RIELLY.
HART, ABLE TO HANDLE THE
REDIRECTION.
TWO SHOTS APIECE THERE  IN THE
>> Jim: WHATEVER IT IS, IT IS AS
SOMETHING THEY'LL ARE
NO REBOUND FOR MARNER, WHO IS
WAITING ONE  TO APPEAR IT
>> Keith: WER PLAY.
MATTHEWS, FIRES FROM ANYWHERE..
GOAL SAVED.
REBOUN.
>> Keith: YOU DON'T WANT TO
OVERSTAY YOUR SHIFT AGHIGHESTHEO
>> Jim: READY FOR SE
BRAUN, GETTING AWAY FROM
BUNTING AGAIN.
.  THAT WAS DICEY FOR THE
FLYERS.
>> Keith: AND HE'S TRYING TO
AVOID THE GREAT DEFENSIVE
COVERARA
NOW, IS JUST A GREAT
READ BY CARTER HART.
HE ACTUALLY TAKES THE PASS
AWAY.
MAPLE LEAFS  WOULD'VE HAD A
THE LEAFS ARE ON IT.T.
REFEREE.
HE DOES KIND OF LIFT THE MORE T
IT WIDE. FROM MATTHEWS, MARNER,
RIELLY GETS IT TO THE  SAFE
RIGHT THERE AFTER THE TURNOVER
BY KEITHTH. TO GET A COUPLE QUA
LOOKS.
END UP SCORING ON THE SECOND
ROUND, AS PROVOROV HEADS OFF
IT .
IT WILL GO TO CENTER NEED TO GE
ACTION ON THE ROUGH AND SEE IF
THEY C CHEM.
A COUPLE HAD COME  OUT ON RE
LAUGHTON  COMES BACK OUT.
HE SHOVELS THAT PUCK DOWN THE RE
SLOT AREA AND FIRES AT HOME.
BRAUN TRIES TO HUSTLE IT BACK,
KERFOOT STEALS IT, ANDLON.
YANDLE GETS IT TO LINDBLOM.
BACK AROUND THE REACH OF
LAUGHTON.
SIMMONDSDS HAS
AN INJURY, THERE'S NOTHING TO
WORRY ABOUT.N'T," AS HE MAKES T
SAVE.
>> Keith: ANOTHER STOP BY HART